my name is Jerry Thomas I'm from
Milwaukee School of Engineering the
title of my talk is a decision process
toolkit and it will be about a brief
introduction to field theory of games
and the toolkit is in preparation for a
course that I'm giving in the spring on
the subject
my name is Jerry Thomas and I'm going to
talk to you a day talk to you today
about some work I've been doing over the
last year some of you may know that I've
been interested in the theory of games
and specifically how to extend game
theory to be a dynamic theory and by
game theory I mean the classic theory of
von Morgan and Morgenstern so in in the
last year my idea was to extend the
concept teach the concept to students
and I met Milwaukee School of
Engineering my thought was to create a
course that would explain to engineering
students this new theory
okay now the problems are these are
undergraduates
typically juniors and seniors they have
a background in calculus probably not
differential equations
unless they're electrical engineers
discrete math and lesser electrical
engineers but the software engineers
computer engineers typically know that
so and in MSOE one of the challenges is
mathematic is still fairly new so in
teaching the course for the for this
group if the first of all explain to
them Mathematica then I have to explain
to them game theory then I have to
explain all the things that forgot about
in calculus and physics and of course I
can't do any of those things altogether
so the idea was to create a toolkit
because engineering students are they
like little toolkits they don't
necessarily do their electrical
engineering work by solving Maxwell's
equations they do it by using SPICE or
some other technique so they they're
very used to using tools and by using
the tools and practicing the tools they
then then ask the question well what
does this all mean
so that was my approach is I was going
to
come down this garden path and by the
time they were finished they would
actually realize oh by the way I now
know mathematic and I now know game
theory and I'm actually applied it to
some problems that I really find them of
great interest to me whether it's
Pokemon or which I've done a little bit
of this this type of course before with
them so I have some experience about the
kinds of things that they're interested
in so let's see if I can get this to go
down sometimes I've had trouble with
this thing sorry oops I probably just
stopped being patient so first of all
what do I mean by by a dynamic game so I
have to I have to explain to them a
whole bunch of things I'm not going to
tell them okay so these are things that
that get initialized in the cells they
ant really never have to look at this
the very bottom is a list of games it's
sort of pasta which they probably will
look at but I can start off with the
idea first of all I have to explain to
them what a game is and then those of
you probably you do know what a game is
for you I have to explain what do I mean
by a dynamic game so what I would
normally do like to teach a mathematic I
use Wolfram's really elementary book and
I and I do the little baby steps for
games I'm gonna do for this talk a baby
step and talk about a game that
everybody here knows everybody is aware
of tic-tac-toe right and of course
everybody knows that there's a solution
to tic-tac-toe what you probably don't
know is how to formulate tic-tac-toe as
a game in terms of the language of von
Neumann and Morgenstern
because the way you play tic-tac-toe is
you put an X someplace and they put an O
and you put an X and they put an awl and
there are different moves right you need
to reformulate that game so that each
player makes one choice and the other
player makes one choice that choice is
like a rule that explains exactly what I
should do and every move no matter what
happens okay
now so what are those choices for
tic-tac-toe well I chose it because you
can look this up on Wolfram Alpha and
Wolfram Alpha tells you that there are
actually nine choices for X and nine
choices for o and that they sort of are
labeled by the places in the diagram but
they don't necessarily mean that's your
move it's just a way of explaining what
the play is
and the only for the first person that
moves there's really only three choices
choice is essentially a here or here or
here three in the middle in the box or a
corner but four oh there's all nine so
in the mind the game theory context this
is a twelve dimensional space and if I
start the game and I know nothing I
don't start in an equilibrium point so
then there's usually hand waving that
says well after you play long enough
that's where you'll get to in a dynamic
theory that's not exactly the right
answer and the dynamic theory you start
someplace with some boundary conditions
you may fall into the hole as an
attraction right or you make circle
around it or you may come zooming in and
zooming out there are many cases that
you would have to walk through and that
would depend upon the details of the
dynamics so in creating a theory what
you're doing is saying it's not a theory
of a point it's a field theory ie it
matters where you are in the space so
I wouldn't worry the students with this
but since this is a Mathematica
conference I have to explain the
approach I take a little bit which is in
a 12 dimensional space thinking about it
as a fluid flow and assuming that the
dynamics are sort of nonlinear which
they typically are I would have to solve
partial differential equations in a 12
dimensional space plus time can I do
that in Mathematica no I can do it in
two dimensions or three dimensions
people who design study airflow have
sort of have a simple solution to the
problem that's been known for a long
time which is I can't solve the problem
exactly but I get a great deal of
insight by imagining that like I want to
do fluid flow
I think of colors a smoke right and I
watch the smoke and that tracks the flow
of the fluid otherwise known as
streamline so I can write down equations
for the streamlines and so I can ask
them to do that they can do that and in
a 12 dimensional space I can write down
flow equations follow the streamlines
and for each each possible strategy I
get oscillations and if I look really
carefully I'll see some strategy doesn't
vary I see this strategy here is
oscillating and I go into the details of
tic-tac-toe those are the equilibrium
strategies in fact but what I'm actually
seeing is because I didn't start at an
equilibrium point I don't stay at an
equilibrium point is this relevant to
other things that we do I spent a lot of
time in in software development as a
manager and I can tell you that although
there are stable systems where you
believe that you're going to deliver
software on a regular basis customers
come in with wild
requests and there's always these
oscillations you're always doing this
oscillation you're always taking a
system and disrupting it and your
question is always after the disruption
what happens well I'd like to do one
step better than stream lines but I
can't go to twelve dimensions so a very
natural choice in a game that has two
players is that rather than they have a
stream line imagine that I could follow
a stream in the Subspace for one player
and the stream in the Subspace for the
other player so each player owns a set
of strategies and the other player owns
a set of strategy so I could imagine
doing a surface of these two stream
lines and watch that over time a caveat
in all of this is although I want to
talk about dynamic systems I need to
build up to dynamic systems in a kind of
a systematic way and like if I was
looking at whether I can look at all the
possible things that could happen in
weather but even if I'm looking at a
hurricane the flows can be stationary so
I'm gonna talk about stationary flow
it's dynamic in the sense that the
particle is moving in time but the rate
at which they move is is stationary but
doesn't mean that simple there can be
vortices I can still have lots of
interesting effects so if the students
get to this point they understand oh
yeah I can I'm moving in space I can
talk about a system that's dynamic and
well one of the questions I might ask is
I have to learn game theory so in doing
the dynamics I would have to say well I
said it's three choices for one player
oops
nine choices for the other player so
there's a game matrix and
the way game theorists solve the problem
is they use linear programming and one
trick is to make a symmetric game where
this is the game matrix here and this is
the same game matrix there and I
introduce a fictitious player so I now
have 13 dimensions and this is a nice
anti-symmetric tensor and I might point
out to students that anti symmetric
tensors are not uncommon in areas like
general relativity and electromagnetism
and this looks exactly like a the field
tensor for the electric and magnetic
field and you can go back and look at
the geometry and yeah you can have
electromagnetic fields in twelve
dimensions okay and rather than solve
the linear programming problem you can
say the rate at which flow changes is
this tensor times the flow and that's
the acceleration the tensor times the
flow is zero the acceleration is zero
that's your stable point when they
accept the tensor times the flow is zero
that's the null space of this matrix now
it's a little mathematics the null space
of that that matrix is the stable point
that you get in linear programming so
this is exactly the same as the max min
solution for game theory so okay I get
that
so am I done well in a dynamic theory
you're actually not done there are there
are a bunch of problems as soon as you
decide to open up the hood one of them
is if I have an electric field and if I
have a magnetic field these are
analogies but if I have them in the the
12 dimensional space I
I must have things like Coulomb's law in
amperes law and even if I'm talking
about things that are stationary I still
have to consider those effects as part
of the boundary conditions so I will
introduce them to some boundary
conditions and some possible choices
that they might make and then there are
a number of other questions that you
have to deal with as a dynamic theory
which you don't have to deal with in
traditional game theory in game theory
the actual payoff value doesn't matter
because if I add a constant to the
payoff matrix it's a higher payoff but
the the max-min solution is the same
think about it again I'm going to do the
physics analogy if I have a magnetic
field in it and it goes it's a nice
little line along this direction and I
go exactly along that direction the
strength of the magnetic field doesn't
matter right but if I'm a little off I
do a little spiral around the magnetic
field the stronger the magnetic field
the stronger the spiral now it matters
so now I have to understand what how the
value plays in and if it's something
that's important well how would you
measure it I mean how does it show up in
your game okay like for tic-tac-toe if I
played the game over and over again my
time scale could be of the matter of
minutes if my game is an economic game
and I talk about a let's say a political
disruption where I wipe out a third of
the population that effect might go on
for generations right and the size of
the effect is now really important
clearly right so
there are some questions that you have
to answer some may be technical
questions you have to answer and so they
can go through all of that they can set
the model up and in the toolkit all they
have to do it will do it for them is at
some point you have to run the magic nd
solved and I chose tic-tac-toe because
it's really a simple game
the downside is it has 12 dimensions
reasons I'm really sensitive about this
thing crashing on me is it takes about
20 minutes for this game to to run but I
ran it so it's it's there and when I
tried to run this game initially I had
to talk to all kinds of experts here at
Wolfram because this thing crashed on me
even though it's a simple two
dimensional PDE I found out that the the
solutions would just go crazy and they
didn't understand why and I wasn't
thinking that this kind of equation was
a convection equation equation because
I'm wealthier I have no heat here but
it's a conduction equation because I
have a magnetic field so I have things
that circulate because they circulate
they change the nature of the equation
so I have to do the same techniques that
you do in heat equations I have to do
here which is to sort of regularize them
that's all under the hood by the way and
I had to do a couple of other tricks in
terms of defining variable once I did
that I could compute a quality measure
that's supposed to be zero to make sure
it is zero and I can start looking at
some of the flows that occur and one of
the things I see is whoops way
I look at the the effort player2 makes
in the game let's say the o and versus
the effort the player 1 makes say the X
as a function of distance along that
their ownership curb their little
streamline and what I at the start it
looks very linear but I now see very
clearly that I get these clear
convection effects and I chose of course
I chose the parameters to make that
looked really awful right it doesn't
always have to look like that but if you
make first given source of parameters
and the same thing
another is both to the stream contours
again in the perfect world this would
look like a nice little set of
rectangles but you see all the nonlinear
effects creeping in another thing to
look at would be the actual flows in the
two directions the flow along ownership
1 the flow ownership 2 and you start you
see even though I'm only in the two
dimensions not in the full 12 I do see
the the creation of little vortices and
turbulent effects do we expect turbulent
effects for sure this is not unlike a
model of weather C cyclones and
hurricanes I would expect to see them
here they're very sensitive to initial
parameters and initial conditions but
nevertheless you can create them since
they have a lot of engineering students
one of the things I can do usually in
the room I have a projector and I have a
cord and I can take the cord and I can
say let's talk about wave patterns and
what we've been looking at is like is
the steady state with no change in the
boundary conditions as a function of
time but if I have a cord and I start
oscillating it right then I really start
to see the two distinctions one is when
I start
the isolation I see a wave go down this
way I see a wave coming back by continue
the oscillations I set up a standing
wave
that's the stationary system but the
standing wave is no longer the standing
wave that we've been looking at the
standing wave is now because I did it at
a certain frequency you would expect if
I changed frequencies there will be
frequencies in which I get resonances
and the thing goes up so I do that to
the model and lo and behold I can create
those standing waves they'll come back
to this in a second and first of all I
can look at some amplitude as a function
of frequency I can say yes I do get
things blowing up I can look at a
particular strategy at a particular time
but you see this and I can see the
effect of this oscillation harmonic
oscillation of a given frequency I
return we said it was at 1 whatever yes
and it it propagates over that area
because I'm operating in this space I do
expect that of these 12 strategies I
should be able to look at each of these
strategies along this ownership surface
which I can do and I see that there's a
lot of structure here are the flows
again there's a lot of structure and you
can see the effect of the various kinds
of inputs I have boundary conditions
here on the edges they generate effects
in the middle some of which were there
already as part of the original game
some of which are simply the effects of
the boundaries
and that initial curve that I showed you
with all the oscillations the
frequencies of oscillations now for the
different strategy and sudden the flows
are quite different so what are some of
the conclusions first of all I believe
the toolkit is a lie I done it very
rapidly for this group the course I have
in mind I've about 10 weeks to lay it
out means I have about 2 or 3 weeks to
get them into Mathematica and game
theory I have a couple of weeks to get
them into the point where they could
reliably understand and how to do this
sort of stuff by week six or seven they
should be in the case a situation to be
able to take these ideas apply it to
their own game and then see what happens
and then they would I would expect them
then to stand up and give a
demonstration talking from in the class
of what they found and some of them are
real fantastic gamers on the web so they
already have experience about what
happens and whether it's optimal whether
it's not optimal they understand the
value of non optimal play in the real
world and how non optimal playing when
the other guy starts being optimal then
you have to change your what you do and
then ask is this modeling doing what you
expect if not is that the fault of the
underlying theory or is that a fault of
your lack of understanding of the
various mechanisms that go into the
model other things that I hope they will
learn is the behavior that we're talking
about is is still a optimization problem
but it is not the max min optimization
problem of game theory it's now being
replaced by if you like a optimization
problem of geometry which is like
finding the shortest path
and they will also get some idea that in
finding the shortest path do a problem
you tend to to figure out how to explain
the problem in a way that's tractable
now an actual game has more than two
players often can have a million players
but many of them don't matter so when
you break it down to a two-person game
or a three-person game you're saying
something about how to ignore the rest
of the effects in physics you never
ignore the rest of the effects you
parameterize the rest of the effects so
they at least capture their energy
effects so one way to capture it is to
think of those effects is cultural and
capture those effects in a in a tensor
that you can say here's the tensor that
has the effects one part of that tensor
is simply the idea of ownership
I always thought ownership would be like
a symmetry of the problem just soar you
know but then I went back and I looked
at like relativity there are symmetries
in space you know general relativity
gets something like a three plus one
dimensional rotation but there are also
dynamic things that are useful
approximations about the way the world
is one dynamic approximation is I saw
trippy okay that's not a symmetry just
says that in a cosmological model at
every point in space things looked
essentially the same if the space were
modeled as a fluid in this case if you
the space was modeled as a fluid there
would be a nice Amin satrapy for each
player that the strategy traces would be
the same and it would be set of choices
for the sky set of choices for this guy
what I didn't expect is it's the
cultural constraints that determine what
strategies I own that's very interesting
right means I don't get to choose my
strategies in some way since the game
chooses all the strategies but other
people could
with sufficient external pressure take
over ownership of things that I thought
I would like to own so what else did we
learn so I talked about steady-state
this is the the path I'm going down as a
path that for my students will be very
familiar which is electrical engineering
path that if I want to learn about
electromagnetism I don't study Maxwell's
equations I study behaviors at first
look at DC Circuit's then they looked at
AC circuits then they looked at
transients so in some very weird way
game theory classic is DC Circuit's what
I just described is AC circuits and for
some future talk we would do transients
well you would do transients we would
have to take into account all the
equations I left out that I haven't in
the theory which is the mat be the the
Coulomb's law and the amperes law and
the the law have attracted how things
get attracted all of those things can be
put in some of those things actually I
do put in because I need to at least see
those effects I need to put in frames of
reference the fact that reference frames
can rotate that's a real thing right in
when they do economics seasonal
variations is very important that's a
rotational effect it's just a harmonic
effect every year certain things happen
so that's what I learned there so in the
end the students will have learned how
to do a theory that has both geometric
attributes cultural attributes to
constraint attributes and will have a
way of applying those attributes the
problems of interest to them so I think
I should probably stop there and see if
there any questions
you
[Applause]